brand folder lets brands collaborate
distribute store and manage digital
assets within our platform devops
velocity at brand folder has evolved
over the last year in quite a big way we
brought operations in-house and our goal
was to really empower our teams to enact
positive change not having a single
group responsible for gating that change
but allowing our teams to innovate on
their own with the support and guidance
of a centralized platform team but
knowing that as we adopt more cloud
native practices we'll continue to be
able to scale
both teams and platform one of the
biggest things for brand folder as a
digital asset management company we
wanted to get all the digital assets
into our system as quickly as we can so
that we can process them and make it
available for our customers for end use
that was one of the challenges that we
ran into like sometimes it would take us
a few minutes sometimes it would be
within a few micro seconds before an
asset becomes searchable within brand
folder little things like creating a
sandbox environment where they can go
click around the google cloud ui but
knowing that once they hit dav stage
prod they're doing it all through
infrastructure as code and terraform
those are things that are making our
environment approachable to the whole
team
but also setting standards in quality
such that we have consistent deployment
across all of those
environments that are higher than that
of sandbox we wanted to provide a
healthy landscape for teams to innovate
and experiment and try out a new few
things the one thing that was really
surprising and exciting was how our
teams quickly adapted and
came up to speed on new technologies and
we were able to
impact change to our customers the
relationship we have with the google
cloud team and especially throughout
this project has been fantastic so we
got a slack channel set up we've got
pretty consistent communication we set
up weekly meetings knowing how high
profile all this work was and how
significant of a change it was for our
operational environment within two weeks
of like go live on all of this stuff the
team reacting to something that they saw
in such a cloud-native way in such a
we're in new technology we're going to
embrace that technology way and just
really getting into the details using
their expertise to solve problems that
we couldn't prep them for it was just
it's just awesome seeing the teams kind
of respond that way learn that way grow
and embrace all of it